all right do you live here at Skid Row
yes I do know where yeah I'm on LA right
now I'm back and forth from Crocker and
Stafford your attack yeah I'm gonna say
it now
hold on I've been down here I see like
five years but back and forth from
regard to Park from here then Marissa
part to Ontario back it's a large slot
yeah
now the whole reason why alone this is
good I stole from my brother you know
you saw my brother my brother your
brother yeah I stole the gun and we went
all bad
and he and I it all started like I went
I was with some girl and I was where I
was working
I've got out of work I went to go see
this girl this girl this girl is getting
high um and I wasn't getting high at the
time I don't she's like oh yeah I got a
knob good I'm good I'm good shut up with
that [ __ ] you know and um and then I was
like fine I just finally said I let me
see it and I started getting high again
a high and I was like damn that's like
damn I can't go home now
um my but then I got into an incident
with another with another group of
people as I was walking down the street
and one of them pulls a gun on me you
know
and
and I got stuck between our car and a
truck and as soon as I turned around to
run I ran behind the truck he started
shooting at me I started shooting at
he's shot about I see like six times all
of them went to the truck I rolled
underneath the truck and he started
shooting underneath the chart and I
could remember him shoot him from the
front of the car from the further truck
and the bullets went it was crazy
so I was I found I was pelvises after
everything happen to like we left I was
thinking me damn I got it I gotta go I
gotta get this foot back you know I
gotta get him back you know that's what
I was thinking you know that was my mind
at that time so I was just like so we
went to my brother's house with lady was
like wanna talk - good morning my sister
was like who's that I was just hurt you
know some girl you know it's just I'm
alright so she went to bed
and I was like I remember I was like the
gun
that's all aside I'll be back so I went
in the garage
and I just I I went in there I pulled it
out I was just like I'll just rip it out
let's just rip it out
let me put this [ __ ] together you know
but but I believe and I took it I jumped
on the bus and I remember if I remember
way back there just like
it's crazy I was craziness after that
what happened a lot happening tonight
I had a lot happen at night you know but
something I'll never forget
I don't know I forget it went home after
everything was done I got rid of
everything everything's got nothing to
worry about
oh I get all in my brother tells me he
come night comes on minutes out they all
just were got a car and I'm like [ __ ]
damn you know him
I guess yeah he already knew he already
knew in his mind already would that
night that I came home something
happened bad and she kept at me like
what's what's wrong with her nothing
about it so he already know like
something was up so he now I don't think
he slept that night I think you just
heard just listen to me walking around
the house and I wanted
I came home and it sounds like two days
before the three days think like three
days before before Christmas
everything's fine everything's fine like
perfect you know and then my brother
tell me
cause me did it like what
and he's that come on gonna grab me is
we're gonna car and I'm gonna follow
because the first thing he does is open
the drawer to him open the little case
you know and no he he opens up the
toolbox and he throws the case at me
and he's hasn't worth of that and tell
what where's Wyatt
I feel like where's it at no it's just
like
I don't know thank you and it's like
it's like
you should [ __ ]
I remember him going inside I'm thinking
[ __ ] this was he's gonna come on it's to
stab me or something at all but my
sister was stripping I think you better
go run rot and I've gotten that running
so that happens it happens no my fault
but I just remember Italian Johnny
tomorrow in the morning Christmas
morning you got to be out of the house
by 8 o'clock
Vicki eat take a shower by 8 o'clock I
want you about its house outside
tomorrow and tomato sauce Christmas Day
because thinks a lot you [ __ ] it up
for all of us and I was just like what
the [ __ ] I think I didn't I couldn't
process it like that
Hydra frozen's it like I did this [ __ ]
to save my life you know
[Music]
everybody's tie my sister
[Music]
just let him stay
and she said oh yeah
who's crazier to say
but yes that's that's that's that's when
I became that's when it started then I
stopped came out I came to MacArthur
Park I went straight to MacArthur Park
that night but that night she was just a
couple it was just a blur it was just it
was it was party from there not don't
mean it was just tag all downhill that
was how many years ago that's it about
I say like
34 now
as violet
24:25
thank you you didn't get car and III was
going to jail in between in between in
between my months and years I was the
years went by I was going in and out of
jail it's constantly in and out jail
fighting cases don't mean I bought the
third strike I thought my third track I
beat it
it would just say it was hit with chaos
you know and it's a go for what happened
on that night
you didn't know I didn't know I never
got caught for that no that was that was
I was stressed out for that yeah the
head were colossi dirty so now I come to
MacArthur Park I'm running a wild man
I'm running with all kind of different
neighborhoods now I've started like I
started
a lot of like everyone around there
which I won't name they're their names
you know but just from you me but I've
seen a lot of [ __ ] damn that's crazy
Oh a lot of [ __ ] like but I think the
drug started with when I was like I'm
gonna go back like when I was kid thank
Chuck started as as young as like I was
nine years old I was nine years old I'll
never forget it
I was kicking on my well my dad's
friends my dad took my dad took me to to
what it was is I guess drug spots I
guess when I was a kid you know kid my
dad used to be a heroin addict so I was
just like I was like I really school so
we went and a my I smelled weed you know
because I always see it's about my
brother smoking weed hi I was standing
right next to my dad's friend and and
and he was staying of smoking waste I
smelled away them and I was like a
Melanie at the wheel and he was like tar
Baghdad sealer let me hit the weed he
was like all right so he let me into joy
but not knowing that it was it had crack
in it so it was so I was like [ __ ] I was
like feeling a certain weird you know
but it's a it's a motor clothes fool you
know the safer hug so I went home that
night I didn't sleep all that night I
was like five I went home my mom's tiny
what's wrong with you what's wrong with
you like nothing nothing and then the
next two to three days went by and then
I got that urge I was supposed to say -
my buddy
what I got so I stole $20 for my mom out
of her wallet and I called it I called
the number he gave me and I told him I
won a 20 so when he goes all right come
down to the same spot so I went down to
since Bonnie came out and he gives me
this white rot right with his white
pieces I thought it was shocked I was
like what says [ __ ] like that's what we
were smoking and he's like you just
flipped marijuana with it or tobacco I
was like [ __ ] I don't have no weed he's
I'll give you some leaves so he gave me
some weed and I was
I was [ __ ] rolling um joins they were
all [ __ ] up but how was it smoke you
know you know but I remember being the
garage and I was just statement one
after that I wouldn't have the other
then it was just like after a while it's
like I was like what I was flying into I
was already in fifth grade I was in the
bathroom and it's very rotten hitting
the foil pipe that I made putting ashes
to put the crack on top so it's a field
trip because I had brillo I was like
what somebody corrected the restroom in
elementary you know corner class all
cracked out you know I went to class I
went to school went to sixth I went to
sixth seventh and eighth I was already
full blown crackhead already by the time
I was in tenth grade I was already
smoking crack straight you know how it's
already like 13 years old just cracked
out run in street smoking my mom's
cigarettes drinking her beer not
listening nothing she had to say you
know hope but this by this time I get
busted I get it I get into my
neighborhood I get it's my neighborhood
like I say like 11 and a half
and then like two weeks after that after
I get it's my neighbor I get busted I
give Buster a Gucci with our life inside
again a jealous I was 23
so I did all of my junior high or high
school so my days due to us 23 years old
you know well by this time my dad might
I'm selling her I'm like for done like
13 years old
I'm like 13 years I'm like I'm like 13
years old and and I'm sending heroin
from jail to to my dad on the outside
you know and and I was my dad's dealer
for I was that my dad's connection
product a lot of years you know because
my dad didn't really like it too many
people that sold him heroin you know so
he would make me go out to her fight the
good woods you know I'm sorry to go out
there and I would be looking around and
I would have been all right you gotta go
if this guy we gotta get the spider team
you know so I think that I'd get [ __ ]
guy I talked to him you're [ __ ] my
dad would get kicked mail and get all
the staff letters
and by this time
I get out I get out for some reason I
get out recent for some reason I don't
know what it was for so I'm out for a
little while and during this time that
I'm out my dad gets it my dad gets out
of jail and my dad said whatever you
have I got that you were busted I'm like
yeah I'm out
it's a modern alarm baby out but where
was some where you had said well my
birthday's tomorrow I'm in Arizona I
said I'll be there tomorrow
so
don't ask me dodge me home it's about my
mom got drunk died
I kept feeding my long beer I'll never
forget it's getting my mom her beer and
her big old cup and I was getting the
brandy oh no it's a [ __ ] mixing it
bro how I was fixing that [ __ ] here you
go
and she was just drinking cups and she
was [ __ ] up I'll never forget it I was
like man here [ __ ] up she couldn't
even walk to the restroom should fall
she was faded I'll never forget I was
laughing I was [ __ ] like yeah it's
[ __ ] it was like the best time of my
life I was like that like what I did to
you now that you are [ __ ] up can you
go wah ha I'm like 14 years old 15 like
yeah you can't walk you know and she
said you son of a [ __ ] your Lobby
[ __ ] up you [ __ ] better [ __ ] my
[ __ ] purse uh yeah so she [ __ ]
she's sitting there and she's smoking
her cigarette falls out man yeah
just round time fam I look at the bus
schedule bus good was on time it's like
six something catch the next bus 756 out
[ __ ] to get there 736 I ran all the way
from El Sereno to City terrorists to
catch the 70 bus and like 25 minutes
that's from a Serena Oliver to see the
terroristic acts city over mate damn I
made it jump down to 78
took knowledge the last turn us all into
the elevator to to Armani bus station I
try to catch the great on there it's
just totally yeah honey it's great grab
lieutenant gets greyhound where you
going here is on there like well hold
you you gotta ride with somebody that's
um I need a ticket
so what we're closed here you need a way
to the next ticket in Clermont but you
need to have someone tell let's say that
you're writing would you in order for
your vocals or not 18 years old [ __ ]
I [ __ ] man I'm pissed I'm tripping out
yeah terrific
and this guy's things I'm not just calm
down I'll just say that your mother on
that view and you can ride with me I'm
not very cool swipe it I go get on the
bus
drop on the ground right now
[Music]
I get off I pay the lady at the window
that way he's like ah you can't get on
you don't have nobody all the night so
that guy right there he's like okay so
they got everything's here whatever but
before we go I'm right [ __ ] I want to
get drunk so I go to 7-eleven that's
nearby
I tell it's not giving us a 7-up slushy
cherry 7up slushy a large one and our
Cisco my cherry cherry flavor Cisco
I pour all the and we leave from the
cerimon station and we're on our way to
Arizona and I'm drinking and I'm
drinking and I pass out I don't even
know where the [ __ ] I'm at I wake up the
bus drivers like wait up hey what the
[ __ ]
bottles over there bottles over here
have all [ __ ] up
[ __ ] it is crazy throw up over here I
was [ __ ] it all faded and um and I
remember I had my last 50 cents in my
pocket it was my last 50 cents and I'm
at the Phoenix bus station I called my
mom cuz I have my grandma's farmer I was
like mama that's the [ __ ] mind you she
thinks I'm at home it's like 2 o'clock
in the morning I get Arizona so it was
like it was like filing like early
morning like barely the Sun barely
coming up so I called my mom and my
mom's like my mom's [ __ ] maid she said
what the [ __ ] you sound like you're in
jail and I'm like nah I'm at the Phoenix
bus station ID grab those phone numbers
now I got two minutes on this phone it's
gonna hang up so if you don't give me
her number I'm stuck out here in the
desert and I'm gonna die
and she's like you're not you you're not
your next door so she does through eight
she calls so Dexter neighbors she takes
out at the boys house and she's like
Milo the Maria asked as a mom and she
said hello he's David over there no he's
not here
that son of a [ __ ] that bought a [ __ ]
she's like why no no no I'll call you
back
did she hate the butter you son of a
[ __ ] you [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
your problem what the [ __ ] are you doing
over there I told you I told you I was
leaving and I told you is Gautam I see
my dad you didn't [ __ ] him believe me
you said I was crazy right
no you're crazy I told god I told you I
wasn't do it and she's like where'd you
get the money I took your money out
cheaper so I'm sorry we got no money
today she was pissed and and she gives
me my grandma's number and my my dad had
just got out of prison that time so she
luckily with my grandma because I kicked
him out of there they'd go out of the
city of Los Angeles my dad was just
they called him a [ __ ] menace to
society to the city of California so
they kicked him out of the state and the
Senate Arizona neither they picked any
other state you can't live here
he's just [ __ ] off the hook you know
a song I started to think I'd get it
from you know I think that's what rubs
off odd so so like so I go and I see him
and I call him item 8 I'm here I'm in
[ __ ] Arizona where's your mom at well
he about just starts talking [ __ ] to my
dad right now shut up man I want to hear
that [ __ ] man and she's that quick cuz
you know I'm [ __ ] out of them young
you know I'm I'm dick got bad ass you
know so I'm talking all kind of [ __ ] sir
she's like wait till you get home I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up
yeah yeah right yeah right yeah I learn
now so Soltan mind you this I'm on
probation
I'm Simon I'm on I'm on supervised
supervision [ __ ] high control [ __ ]
probation again gang I got three
probation I got regular I got drugs that
I got gang-related probation at all at
that time I'm not even supposed to be to
stay I take off home
well yeah check this out
[Music]
hello yeah he took off where'd he go he
went to Arizona I can't control him
anymore
all right bye
come days go by grandmas on wings
oh [ __ ]
there there the Fred door [ __ ] cuffs
changed all of this [ __ ]
my grandma's freaking out my grandma
it's not that sound obviously nobody
really knows about this you know my hand
don't even know about this you know this
after that we came here we'd be together
that's it
you gotta love my daddy because okay I
got most Heidi both of us you know I
mean my dad was supposed to be at that
address
they're supposed to be somewhere else so
so my aunt gets just both busted they
take me back gotta play they fly me back
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] like on a bar for
playing I [ __ ] I'm talkin like Eric on
one and [ __ ] you know [ __ ] chain it up
[ __ ] [ __ ] in a [ __ ] with all kind of
people looking at me then Fox on my back
and my dad [ __ ] up
cause jail again
I'm almost close to going back to jail
again
by this time my dad comes back over here
he gets out and he comes back to my
mom's old house and he tells me hey
[ __ ]
do you have anything I like
and he said come on
I'm like dude I don't have nothing I
gotta take these to taiga groundwater
court tomorrow
I gotta take these and you know I gotta
take this and he's like come on mijo
then we get something
and I know our sister snow not this one
and he's back come on just give me three
doors that give you three with that I
said three that's it just three so just
give me five five five
and I think in five the [ __ ] you're
gonna do with five I ask them oh stop
the river man I do too but I make my
money I'll bring it to you
salad Zach [ __ ]
all right all right giving some
I tell them at
be careful you know
I gave him five I'm three at first and
he was like ah honey three I see yeah
that's enough but then that means only
could do one I'm like that's it that's
enough
and he's like [ __ ] kobata buggin
buggin buggin no [ __ ] you know
these things do you have anyone give I
might give him one more so it's all mere
four four and [ __ ] out that far
yeah checking for balloons and 40q a man
a kid I told my give you some weed but
then I was like [ __ ] em until that last
500 let me give them put it inside the
wheel and give it to him so when he
opens it up gonna have that last one you
know he'll get at all he gave it to me
you know and then I remember him calling
me telling me a meal I've seen when you
know when you open the wheel a I found
that other what the other balloon and
I'm like [ __ ] I'm like all right
he said thank you and I'm like I'm like
you better not do them all and it's like
I'm not I'll see you in the morning
all right as I keep better come home
sucker
you better come home
yeah well I have my house
I'll have fun and if I would see I don't
know why I was starting tonight I came
home my mom was talking [ __ ]
my dad's till I came home and I was
stacked with the [ __ ]
why is he nobody caught like the [ __ ]
it's like lost eat
and
oh no wait wait wait lately before my
dad dies my dad stay at the house
my dad my dad my dad's at the house in
California he just had got out of prison
and I give him and this is this is two
days before he gets a phone call that my
grandma dies he's not supposed to be in
California and this is the end and he
gets a phone call we get the phone call
the next and I'm tired I'm what the [ __ ]
like my hand calls and and she's [ __ ]
freaking out and I'm [ __ ] tired I'm
tired what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
going on the [ __ ] went out to tell me
she's that I didn't talk to your mom and
talk to your mom and I'm like Tyler what
the [ __ ] went on you know I'm tripping
out on uptown I'm not gonna give you the
phone didn't she tell me
she's just something like your dad's
dead I don't like what the [ __ ] that's
right it's crazy that was like what you
mean I like it she's like yeah you gotta
go identify on my [ __ ] and I started
that's crazy he died without D from all
the balloons that I gave him
yeah spray-z
I was 40 years old
I'd add that in 2000-2001
that's crazy
so I go
I open the door
and then she see him later it's the wall
against the door you know
and just like
I just remember just hitting Ethel
and now once my dad died it was just
like it was just like nobody could tell
them happy
Iona fly back to jail
I go back to jail
now now begins I'm getting older
my mom's like tripping out on me I get
out I get out of jail my sister's like
[ __ ] your change you're different you're
a gang member now just all this crazy
[ __ ] just
she said that I was just like tripping
out on like if you were to think you're
different now
cuz I've bit my head bent but I got my
busted for so many years you know and
everybody's all you're just like your
dad and out of jail and out of jails and
you just like what of please you know
but when I was growing up was free it
was it was ours
you know I I dealt with a lot of [ __ ]
like when my brothers and my sisters
they would they would [ __ ] up I get it
my mom would drink she'd get drunk I
should be Dave aunt Claire I don't know
her she just pull out the extension cord
bro and beat the [ __ ] out of me no I'm
just like what the [ __ ]
like dude what the [ __ ] your problem
I was like
[Music]
I don't know it's like probably like
seven years old I'll never forget it I
was at the mall I was like I said maybe
seven or eight years old I was already
like I was I was already walking behind
counters taking jewelry out of their
jewelry cases at the Etta
at the Pasadena mall with my mom my dad
and everybody you know and getting away
with the [ __ ] well what time I get
caught
I get caught my mom [ __ ] takes me
down my dad says my dad's in the rest of
my mom snatches me up and she takes me
downstairs and I remember my mom's
telling my dad
she's going in the car and she took me
to the car and
I don't know if she thought it was crazy
and she pulled out the extension cord
and beat the [ __ ] out of me and wouldn't
stop I was in the backseat like they try
to block this [ __ ]
and then I just remember though I just
remember the side window breaking to the
car breaking the window and my dad
snatched my mama Wow snatch her up and
put her guest
I love wreck a better
like by the floorboard of the car let me
tune like the shifter that sounded my
mom that's the last time you're gonna
hear my boy and she and from that day on
she she she never she starts she didn't
stop eating me but after a while I was
like like she would deal was that guy
was already kid I was that guy said I
was getting older and it was it wasn't
even hurting she wouldn't even hurt her
more know his type
then she would try to like eat me when I
was older like in front of my [ __ ]
friends and I would [ __ ] push her I
would I was bad you know I mean like I I
almost blew my mind I almost blew my
mom's windows out in her apartment um I
would luckily I didn't blow them all out
because we're sitting there making meth
I was out of control
I was just really what made Mickey met
yeah out of my mom's house this is when
I get out and my mom's one really what
are all these buckets and all these
things always hold this is yeah this is
Dom I'm right
I'm already I'm already older I'm like
27 28 30
so like so on I'm making this McInnis
stuff and I remember my my homie pouring
this alone
ammonia nitrate stuff this liquid into
the into this other pot and you put it
on top and you for it filters in and
there's a flask that you have to take
off so the pressure so the pressure
built up and oh man I won't explode you
like breathe it and I tell them don't
don't pull so hard there are mean if if
it doesn't come out dude we'll just
abandon it form will go oh it doesn't
want to come off
I tell him bro you got too much
condensation on the inside of that
shit's not gonna come off and sit back
in bro
you pull that [ __ ] off in a spar
kids we're all going out and this will
now I got her I got her I got her I got
her don't know use a bottle with the
sprayer and spray so about it's the
water from the insect falls out and the
steam comes out just let it just rides
out for just put off and it still work
come on
so he's like oh he just hit it and as he
hits it it it catches a paper in the
house I don't know where the vapor came
from probably the hose that was the I
don't know and it flashed I don't know
what it was but it was a big-ass
fireball to the whole house like like we
were right when it went up we were on
fire we were [ __ ] them we were wrong
and you couldn't even see the fire it
was like alcohol fire like you know you
burn it and I get that all feel and you
can't see the fire to the raises into
light like that I'm on fire how [ __ ]
throwing myself I'm on fire and and I
put myself in the couch and I picture
myself all burning up mom Burt has his
face all burnt up and in my home he's
like my arm damn you got the [ __ ]
flash he got the flash back on that [ __ ]
when he pulled the ding up the flash the
liquid from the inside flashed
overflowed and foamed up like right like
if you could see food in a pot of
boiling water and he lets sit there it's
just gonna overflow
and I mean so because all the mercury
push it all out was one sort of once
what it does it just pure salt salt
water out of the out of the out of the
food and that's what happened and it got
on my hair and his skin just just licked
off it was crazy
not mine his and it did we call it
beating out his arms read from right
here now
yeah I took the whole pigment of his
skin off small come pinky
yeah it doesn't go hey did you hear the
water tough as to did it said well you
were a fire I said so what at least I
got by has he still got his hands but
it's already now bad burned I can real
bad I tell you you can see the like I
clearly you can like literally Frankie
moves you can already see that the
months
like like you can see the skin the
thickness of his skin and this
aggressive is gone like your deity
gloves or something that's crazy it was
weird but um
so let's the cops come
[Music]
when those get blown out neighbors would
have stopped blown out um I go to jail
again I heard this typer for
manufacturing methamphetamines so they
tried he gave me all night
manufacturing within a thousand yards of
the school zone oh man bro charges went
from sucking all right I'm getting out
maybe in about 90 days to six months to
[ __ ] the rest of my life in jail
I'm like
for this [ __ ]
for a hundred twenty four grams you're
gonna give me life and all these heavy
everything that they found in the
apartment they found bits and pieces
because we were already had I mean got
rid of a lot of stuff but they thought
enough to to basically can not condemn
the house the apartment until they
cleaned it up for like about a week
well they [ __ ] they try to get me for
that that that child's Dangermond like
okay
like 324 charges of that [ __ ] because of
all the children in school it was some
hot crazy odd [ __ ] crazy number it
was like [ __ ] stupid
and I told her that's [ __ ] I'm gonna
fight it so I get out on bail I'm on a
bail my sister's like what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do I'm like I don't know I'm
stressing out you've got a quarter and
I'm like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna do a
speed shop why not I got nothing to lose
so I just reach out
damn see I fired my lawyer at that time
I did I PD well I fired two people so
for that to to PD so far already and now
I'm like [ __ ] Who am I gonna go for oh
man I get a state of pointing Wow like
what the [ __ ] is this is that guy yeah
my name is such as such I'm a state
appointee from the state of California
you're lucky to get one of these I'm
like a paid lawyer that someone paid for
you that you just don't even know about
just put like that and and and they're
paying for you to bring this case okay
so you're like a rishis like just put it
like this I'm not gonna lawyer that like
a paid lawyer that's something about for
you that you don't even know that just
sort of help you out so I'm like okay
so
[Music]
I'm on bail all right so they do they do
the sting rule and they've all right
well we're gonna come back to tomorrow
we have we have we have reached [ __ ]
our substitute offered to assist section
CC - David Sanjay who AKA ique from
badly without the ball is not just not
[ __ ] you know so I'm like all folks will
get to come back to court tomorrow like
yeah so I'm like
David you know David David could do
anything in in in a maximum of we've got
to be back in court in 18 hours less
than that well David goes goes kicks in
with his girlfriend I'll be in court
morning bright and early I'll be good
[Music]
Wow I get busted the next morning
I like like it 7 o'clock in the morning
for shooting at a car [ __ ]
for shooting at your car in Palmdale
thank you
nothing happens look nothing happens no
cops come the first day no cops come I
fired this car all shot all the whole
clip people are looking at the windows
and I'm like well yeah I'll shut the
windows oblige
no cops nobody shows up I remember the
fire I fired 10 shots from a knife from
a 9 i discard a Dada today's air honesty
uh what the [ __ ] even my house
they SWAT him with Palmdale PD Sheriff
Brook wouldn'ta my house raid in my
house
I will god I heard doors come open yeah
I see someone in the hallway over there
and I was like what the [ __ ] I took off
right into the back window cuz I already
knew what it was and I grabbed the
shotgun
I grabbed the gauge that I was gonna
throw out the window and far as I as I
go and I get the gauge I told the gate
food I threw it it hits the lip of the
the roof of the house I'm thinking [ __ ]
this shit's gonna [ __ ] fall down it's
gonna land right there
and here comes a [ __ ] sheriff running
down I'm like this in the window and I
have then you're storing the gun in
there good
fall straight into the [ __ ]
straight into the to the to where the
water runs sits perfect can't see [ __ ]
pull around back
yeah and this money this is a 12-gauge
this is a nine shot pistol grip right
addition of all spring this is this is
this right addition this is you you just
don't go find one of these at in here
your gran stores you know
there you can't get it nine shots they
don't make it twelve get check that
that's that's next red sir that's extra
you know especially automatic were you
just cocky so that she was a badass
luggage so I throw it yeah Todd the
sheriff runs up
don't even [ __ ] move and I'm thinking
[ __ ] this fools see me throw the gun and
I'm just like oh [ __ ] I'm done so they
take me out the window [ __ ] they
handcuff me and they throw a file in
front of me I'm thinking what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] and then it was another one
her pictures start to scatter out the
[ __ ] is that all right
[ __ ] is this a drone 9,000 miles in the
sky took 156 pictures
of the whole thing
they were already watching my house
had been watching my house for three
months with the jump so they got me have
more charges and more charge more charge
first deal first I go to court first day
to court you know you're getting you got
to get to limiting your preliminary to
give run over your charges let's know
what you're being charged with so the
next time you come to court that you're
this is what you're gonna be arraigned
for you know
well my first preliminary was we're
offering you 22 years with 80
[Music]
[ __ ] 22 years ago 80 a mine is this I'm
with my girl I got I got my girl this
one Karen at the time and she she she's
[ __ ] tripping out she's telling you
that [ __ ] you're going off but mind
you all this time I'm sitting her and
she's looking at me like as we're going
to jail she's looking at me like oh my
god you had these things in the house
and I'm like whoa hold on hold on hold
on and then they find the drugs they're
verse but those are her drugs and she
said that's why you were in my purse
we're never [ __ ] aah dog Alice like
you was like what the [ __ ] you know him
and she's dying so you've been on drugs
this whole time
we could tell we gonna work through it I
was like oh my god this is [ __ ] good
you're [ __ ] good I was like that the
[ __ ] you talking what you told me just
like I said I'd had no idea those were
there
she's like N and for him to put my life
in danger as I'm sleeping to put him
underneath me always oh [ __ ]
you're really [ __ ] plastering he's a
lawyer you know so the cops that call
you [ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ]
isn't that [ __ ] looking at the cop
like a dick you're believing this [ __ ]
okay she gets out of jail first I don't
know what are the reader I think your
sister bailed her out I don't know what
it was but she got out of jail before I
do can I'm still fighting this case now
and and I'm telling her like we're on
the bus on the way back were on the bus
and I'm tired she's like what they offer
you I was a doubt for me 22 years or 80
should i what the [ __ ] I was like what
they ask you 32 months
I like what the [ __ ] you mean she's like
they separated her case I why because
they bound you over all right what the
[ __ ] I like so they [ __ ] railroaded
me so they so they know what the [ __ ]
you were doing and they [ __ ] just
said all right [ __ ] it is how we're
gonna run their kids you're gonna
separate him
for what reason due to her statement
staying out she never knew so it made me
look like I was so they when I all right
[ __ ] it
she doesn't [ __ ] I'm gonna have a record
will break you off a deal Gifford and
we'll let him run his ass ball they [ __ ]
it oh man and I was [ __ ] pissed I was
like where's your next court date I
don't know you I'm over here it's all
I'm done you're gonna [ __ ] fry me
we're go go back to court
[Music]
dad out of the DA offers me huh sixteen
years I told her and I was like first
stuff
where's the gun I didn't dawn I was a
cold hot roll I could get out too
[Music]
maybe not right now but maybe in about a
couple of years I could get help maybe
about less than five years I get out
[Music]
so I [ __ ] tell the judge I tell my
[ __ ] hard [ __ ] you I don't need you
so I tell the judge you know at this
time I'm speaking now my lawyers telling
me shut the [ __ ] up time shut the [ __ ]
up your fire and I tell them I tell the
judge you know for records you know like
I want to know where the guns at yeah
you shows you that it shows that I was
shooting a gun but where's the gun no
gun no evidence no [ __ ] case so I'm
like okay so we we have to okay we meet
you goes back and the DA is arguing over
it or like it's still abiding coca dude
is a gang member
I'm like if what was I shooting a camera
can't tell it doesn't have no voice no
nothing you can't hear it it shows me it
could be anybody it doesn't show that I
was talking to say nothing it's like how
can I say it's like it's like if I show
you pictures of me shooting have
somebody a car you can't go off by that
yeah so it's like you can't boy it is
it's your same dismissed so I'm like so
that's that charge from attempt murder
goes down to goes down to um assault
with a deadly weapon
but where's the only weapon dismissed
okay give me a violation that you have
eyelash to the [ __ ] hurt my Perot head
of God so they go from 22 to 16 and I
told him I take I take eight-way right
now outside of employers right now
they're like 10 so I did like they gave
me Tim I have I did like a little bit
less than I'm a little bit ah a little
bit more a little bit less than like
four I was I was supposed to go home in
two I could have went home at two but
the day I was four I [ __ ] I had to do
something you know man I just tell my
sister I'm not coming home I see a
couple here I see it at uber years I had
no choice you know I mean but it was
[ __ ] up you know I was like something
you don't want to go on exist you're
coming home to all right just don't
expect me just yeah just something
happen and that's it like you're serious
you're gonna pull this [ __ ] you're right
I can't do nothing like I've talked to
you later you know and [ __ ] she's
like what
she's not got [ __ ] heard about that
[ __ ] on the news oh you guys are [ __ ]
prison or killing each other you guys
are [ __ ] off the walls you serve a
[ __ ] I don't want to talk to you how
like what the [ __ ]
and she's like she's like she's biting
me letters and she's like you're in the
hole just - how long you're gonna be
there and say well I'll be here for her
here I don't know another three years so
I mean I'm in the hole for like six
months
now 24 hours I'm losing my mind
I have no stole interaction with don't
body I have a cell that's where lots of
the lightning and you guys know walk me
like that and that's door and that's the
wall I'd be standing there and I'm gonna
go ahead I'm Saturn's yeah I know we
know just a light I look like I look at
chicken you like a chicken breeder okay
I like a window the right
how does like you sleep you tiny thing
right here they feed you through a whole
wallet
five minutes showers how many years if
you go to prison overall here you're
hoping at 3:35 the day for update 434
yeah
Allah then Allah exists
good fifteen years of my life in and out
and I know out and I was like you're
crazy you just you just like your dad
yeah I've never seen myself like that
but so I was like I started noticing
like yeah I am I am like my dad
I have his ways you know then once my
dad that guy said it goes I'll go back
to what my dad died
I started stabbing heroine again
and I came out here again I love you and
control me about always [ __ ] just get
out the house so I don't give a [ __ ] on
your [ __ ] I still a car [ __ ] I wrecked
your car on the [ __ ] I left it on the
train tracks and blamed it on my brother
into this date my lungs still Deeks is
my brother
ha ha ha my dad figured that on my
brother I slowed the car I wouldn't
enjoy right I got the car stuck on the
train tracks and the car I [ __ ] my bed
to frame now driving the car change that
tire no other dog [ __ ] Theo's in a
movie or some [ __ ] and [ __ ] train
stopped right there
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] I'm over there
hiding and [ __ ] on the car that [ __ ]
Bullock off the tracks they [ __ ] take
it back to my mom's house and my mom
[ __ ] wah I don't know stole my car
and she would like my brother my brother
right now and I'm [ __ ] that's great
it's crazy you just I started so I came
out here and I said that right here on
San Pedro and I was kickin with these
people
Mona Josey they were like big their own
daughters you know but uh
I remember
her brother being in federal prison and
I'm talking to a lot of phone and I'm
night what's up and he's like hey I
don't know you I'm in federal prison
right now I'll be out soon
just tell such as such that you're
taking over there's no more whatever you
have you give to me and I'll take care
of the rest of the business but from
this point forward you're fired
you know so I fired that full and he
made me his runner so I'm running in
packs and heroin throughout this little
city you know
and and I'm I'm [ __ ] coming up I'm
making money
make it mine in my last ship my mistake
I was shipping out everybody she say
it's crazy now
and
I get off I start getting all [ __ ]
depressed and my dad is mad at my
grandma so I start staffing heroine
again and um I was with this girl and
everything else is this girl and
and my homies telling it what the [ __ ]
you doing fool what the [ __ ] you doing
gay you're gonna stab heroin again
you're gonna start up again
you stopped food I was like [ __ ] it so I
am I [ __ ]
Oh as I get out that's what I want to
feel
while my gnome with this girl and I'm
all [ __ ] up and I guess I forget that
I already had fixed so I get the other
one and I should have the other one well
after I don't know I'm not dude I don't
even remember going out I remember II
they stick it in a noir um so I'm not in
a tent I'm on a body in the street
inside 10 the 10th I can fold like
coming up should I walk you know and I'm
laid out in the 10 like that and it's
their Street and my homeboy Touche
that's right there was I seeing the girl
like scattering on her [ __ ] I could fast
oh [ __ ]
and she see her and I go into my socks
anyone
hey she got up she took off running
Eddie's a sharky sharky no answer any
like what the [ __ ]
left will always answer no matter what
he could be [ __ ] what they could be
any time of the night haven't gotten
let's get an answer and I didn't answer
so he waited at tenth on me without I
don't know no I don't even know but I
knew this I can hear everything I hear
everything
thank miss phrase I hear everything but
I'm out I'm telling myself wake up you
gotta get up it just wasn't getting up I
just just did just see I'm not just some
um once I tried it just was doing it and
now I'm sad about my ni ma I'm [ __ ]
them down dead I would I come here for
like maybe get up but I just I just
couldn't you couldn't do it there was
just there was happening and
it's like
I carry the paramedics tell the homie
move we got this
and I remember him [ __ ] working on me
on the ground but on my eyes are open I
can see him and I'm just looking up but
I just can't even bring my eyes I'm
[ __ ] I'm just like out but I care
everything and it's like God don't like
that would you put your time and it's
like we're at six minutes but we're at
five we're at five minutes 48 seconds
and you start we're gonna call it at six
[Music]
so at six they kept working at me at six
and there's still nothing so
[Music]
so they stack can fill them stop
and then I'm thinking what the [ __ ] are
you doing fool you stuck in bro and then
he's like nah [ __ ] that
no it's not gonna do this and he runs
have a chest like two more times and I
got a chopper I got home I get up
so but mind you this he cut off my
clothes off so I get up not knowing what
the [ __ ] going on freaking out I'm
tripping out cuz I know what happened
and I took off running down the street
I'm but a thank you right now she don't
know where the [ __ ] I'm going but I'm
just trippin cuz I just wake up and
everybody's around me so they chased me
down the street they find maybe I have
to help [ __ ] you with discovery like
work you're tripping out what the [ __ ]
get away from me no I don't eat you guys
that cup good and they're like do you
know what you just went through it's
like you almost went through the wall
myself about seven minutes of no oxygen
to your brain bro because you I don't
know what you're doing here live bring
your eyes or whatever you're doing her
hair is part of that but I've been on
this [ __ ] thing for like but 18 years
of captain she forever I never seen
anything like this
he's like I don't know how you're still
alive you should be like right now the
hospital fighting for life I like [ __ ]
I'm thinking I'd alley
I still don't get it should be now and
I'm like because I'm ask you some
questions and
it was just debates if you go to the
hospital or not and I was like I don't
have to go right because if you answer
these questions right you don't go I'm
like all right it was what's color the
sky you know it's that
make what cut at the ground
[Music]
black
oh my fingers am i holding up too
I'm gonna fear that oh yeah
I got one more for you I'm gonna clean
em out you know I don't have an exact
Punky's - hey it was like he's our gear
[ __ ] lucky I was like what the [ __ ]
they say it's a slow house that yeah
because you're gonna feel like that for
a couple of the mindset for a couple
days but a couple weeks that's all right
and then I started noticing look things
like my legs were dragged I caught
walking my legs were just dragging with
the [ __ ] no inch of I just like stutter
a lot I just thought I just told myself
thank you I told me if you give me a
second chance at life
you only have when you get I don't worry
knows but the next day I get high and
the next day I [ __ ] I'm sick you know
that's why I slam again and and and I
get high I don't [ __ ] thinking [ __ ]
here we go then I remember throwing up
like the worst set of my life looking at
I doubt the hair went ahead and I just
threw it over the fence ah
and I [ __ ] and I get busted I get
busted like couple days later and I go
to jail
I stood up for 22 days when no sleep no
sleep no sleep for 22 days for the last
15 days that I kicked that stood in the
window of the door of my cell at every
hour of every hour of every single hour
for the kid for the [ __ ] prick before
it was like the first one he was like I
was like and you're here any second damn
you've been here for the last 15 days in
this window exactly on time I'm like
yeah cuz I know it's have you heard of
ear he's like no Steve wheezing he's
like you're looking crazy
and I remember getting out of jail and I
was like [ __ ] I stopped you now
other servers I'm [ __ ] I never
haven't got I'm not gonna say having a
high since I got high like I broke that
tears that I had um you know heroin I
was don't know maybe that last year was
last year
I got high with my buddy my buddy was
getting high with the saw me in the car
and he was an eight full you want to get
hired up and I was that fool with the
[ __ ] you asked me that question for full
don't do that so we dig anything he's
magic
I dig for NASA for all due to that floor
time so I know I don't get hiding I
don't especially now you know I know
[ __ ] you know I'm gonna piss so the [ __ ]
for who before I could do that for dick
and I thought [ __ ] it I'm gonna get high
for gravity no he's like no I think
don't get hiding I'm just playing with
you I was like aha now you see you don't
give me out one you only get high why go
crazy did you trip out like fool that
[ __ ] I'm doing him right the
McDonald's I heard the street I get high
I fix what up and I'm like [ __ ] a [ __ ]
if I do this much I'm all a daily [ __ ]
that so I swear like half of it out I do
like maybe like ten units and I'm like
[ __ ] I'm all over the place in the car
I'm [ __ ] out of it [ __ ] you don't
autograph don't order control [ __ ]
whatever I did everything I touched just
[ __ ] fell apart everything I tried to
touch the radio up for the knob fell off
and turn to give the soda the sort of
fell all over the car I tried a smokey
singer broke the sea route from burn a
seat and we're tied up in a brand new
car
you know who let her see it and he's
like [ __ ] you just [ __ ] it stop [ __ ]
stop but I'm like what stay still bro
just a [ __ ] still make it home I'm
like all right dick you say everything
you touch just [ __ ] it up
just leave it alone just stay still as I
think I'm sorry Dickies I start to fall
take the hope you got you [ __ ] up how
are they [ __ ] you and I got oh I got to
this place where I was at I don't even
remember going in there I was so [ __ ]
up
just like out of it you know do you say
yeah I still get high
yeah I still do get higher I won't sit
down or lie to you
because then I wouldn't be honest with
myself I couldn't admit that I do have
an addiction you know I do have proud of
my hell but I just for the meantime
right now just so at Cobra no it's about
coke what might the what what I feel
[Music]
sighs this type day for day you know do
you mind if I get on a cigarette no
honey water yeah you know it's just like
it's it's it's just it's it hard you
know like my hand she tries to help me
out I figured if I don't change right
now with anybody helping me or with me
being hard-headed and stubborn and me
being out here I'm gonna be dead yeah
I'll be my dad I'll be yeah I'll be dead
so I figured [ __ ] it that's why I'm home
to over here cuz it's just too much over
there for me it's too hectic it's like I
sleep here I could relax for here I
don't have to worry about something I
mean
over there I'll [ __ ] I [ __ ] all I
hear is sharky sharky sharky sharky
sharky sharky sharp knife what the [ __ ]
bro like okay my sit down and take a hit
without their [ __ ] say my name and
this time damn I'm like what the [ __ ]
and it's like everybody's like that's
like all the whatever I have I say bro
you know cuz I'm trying to I'm telling
you but the next three months that I'm
working I'm saving up these next two
months of checks if I do start working
at this Christmas thing I'm gonna get a
car first time I get my apartment cuz
how this SRO get your free or houses
[ __ ] that that's that [ __ ] lazy way
that's [ __ ] ticket that's lazy [ __ ]
help me if I keep a 33 [ __ ] you [ __ ] 30
down man I want pay 750 or 850 are you
pay so much I paid thirty seven dollars
dig well that's you because you got
people helping you're kicking out of my
taxes [ __ ] you know exact you
can you [ __ ] crack yet you are I mean
that's just coming out of my pocket so I
mean and it's just to me it's more of a
work ethic you know you you work harder
for which again you get the better
results you work [ __ ] you don't do
[ __ ] at all what are you gonna get
here's a [ __ ] brownie on a cup of
water well how come he got a [ __ ]
double-stuffed chocolate chip cookie and
milk well if you [ __ ] decided to
paint the backdrop not [ __ ] just
spray sparkles all over
yeah you know and I've noticed myself
looking at all these cars they can [ __ ]
that [ __ ] and that's his [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] family and it's
you know some of them okay yeah they get
that [ __ ] here you go here you go
either this world but a lot of them is
that was like how can I be mad I'm mad
at him because I'm mad at myself because
I can't because I know I could be there
but I just don't want and it's like why
am I mad at him he just put a little
more he put he put he he read the
directions on the other box and I
decided I know how to put it together
you know what I mean
so that's where I went wrong you know he
followed the book in the directions and
I said I just look at the pictures that
I'll get this he'll realize it all
anyway I'm a handful of screws by the
tire over here do you know everything's
crazy [ __ ] just if [ __ ] like that
yeah so that's just that's that's that's
it he's what you're talking about yeah
it was really yeah
how Paul is it all over the place yeah
well I try not to you know
that compares this this chapter of my
life